Welcome to the deep dive.
So you probably saw it just a
few days ago, that post from
David Pak.
Man, it kind of sparked that
familiar online buzz.
Oh yeah, I saw that.
One, it read, 67% of Americans,
including half Republicans,
think Trump is covering up
Epstein, evidence he's losing
his base fast.
And you know, if you were
online, you felt that immediate
surge, the likes, the comments
all saying the cult is finally
cracking or they're waking up.
There was this real sense of
catharsis, almost relief, like,
OK, finally, finally things are
shifting.
It's a powerful feeling, right
that the dam's about to break.
And that specific reaction, that
collective hope, well, that's
exactly what brings us to our
core question for this deep
dive.
Is this really the moment the
collapse people expect?
Or is something else going on
or?
Yeah.
Is there maybe a much deeper
misunderstanding about what
that, you know, the Red Hat
actually symbolizes and why some
scandals, even ones that look
really bad, just don't seem to
land?
OK, so our mission today is
really to unpack those
assumptions.
Exactly because this whole deep
dive is grounded in a really
compelling analysis, we found it
challenges those common ideas
about political loyalty, about
public trust.
It's kind of a shortcut to
understanding these weird
dynamics.
Yeah, it offers a different
lens.
So let's unpack this then.
I mean, think about it, How many
times have we seen these
attempts to engineer a political
downfall and they just seem to
to bounce right off?
It feels like a lot.
Our research shows people have
been predicting this guy's
political end since day one.
Pretty much.
It's just been this parade,
hasn't it?
Indictments.
Access Hollywood.
Impeachment 1.
Impeachment 2.
Ukraine classified documents.
January 6th.
Books, podcasts, poets or
winning editorials, you name it.
And every single time the
narrative was the same, wasn't
it?
OK, one more revelation, one
more poll, one more gotcha
moment, and that will finally
shatter the illusion.
But, well, here we are.
And that's exactly where our
source material really zeroes in
with its main argument.
The illusion, it argues, isn't
actually with the supporters,
it's with the people expecting
the collapse.
The core mistake, it says, is
mistaking moral clarity for
strategic leverage.
OK, what does that mean exactly?
It means thinking that just
because you feel you're morally
right, that automatically gives
you the power to change things,
to sway people.
This whole idea that the system
corrects itself, that a facts
alone will do the job well, that
only really works when people
still trust the system doing the
correcting.
And the crucial point here?
The absolute key is that the Red
Hat is seen as first and
foremost a symbol of withdrawal
from that trust.
It's basically a statement
saying we don't believe you
anymore, whether you use the
media, the government, the
courts.
Right.
They've checked out of trusting
those traditional sources.
Exactly.
That's a really powerful idea,
that breakdown of trust.
But OK, if it's not just a cult
and the system isn't self
correcting for this group, what
is?
What actually holds this base
together?
Then let's shift focus.
This is where it gets really
interesting, understanding who
makes up this coalition.
Yeah, it's super important to
see.
It's not just this amorphous
BLOB of cultish loyalty, as the
source puts it.
It's described more as a layered
coalition.
And what binds them together
isn't just one person.
What that person represents for
them Things like defiance,
vengeance, and symbolic
inversion of a cultural order
they believe has humiliated
them.
Humiliated them how?
Well, for some it might stem
from feeling left behind
economically, the economic
abandonment.
For others, it could be
religious displacement or
cultural dislocation, or just
feeling like they've spent years
being told that.
I don't know, their job, their
accent, their skin color, even
what they eat marks them as
somehow backward or morally
inferior.
It's that deep feeling of being
dismissed or looked down on by
the mainstream culture.
Wow.
The source we looked at uses
such vivid language for this.
It describes Trump as a middle
finger wrapped in a flag, dipped
in gold plating and shouted
through a bullhorn.
Yeah, that's quite an.
And it points out his his
vulgarity wasn't a bug, it was a
feature.
Meaning that rough around the
edge of style wasn't a negative
for his supporter, no.
Quite the opposite.
It signaled he wasn't one of
them.
You know, the establishment, the
elites they don't trust, and the
contrast it draws is really
stark.
His sins are seen as pedestrian
and televised, sort of obvious
and out there.
Relatable.
Almost.
While the sins of the elite are
perceived as whispered,
obfuscated and ritualized,
hidden, complex, maybe even
sinister, very different
categories of wrongdoing in
their eyes.
And what's really fascinating
connecting from that is how this
whole perspective helps explain
why something like the Epstein
allegations just don't seem to
register with this base, OK?
Yeah, how does that?
Work well.
The analysis digs into what it
calls the populist right
cosmology, basically the
underlying worldview of this
group.
And within that worldview
there's often this pre-existing
almost automatic assumption that
everyone in power is complicit
in child trafficking, satanic
ritual and globalist blackmail
networks.
It's a dark view.
So they already suspect the
worst of the powerful.
Pretty much.
They don't necessarily need hard
proof in the way others might
demand it.
Their belief system operates
more on archetype, on
fundamental character types and
narratives rather than just
evidence.
OK.
So if that's the assumed
background radiation, sort of
where does Trump fit into that
picture for them?
He's obviously powerful and was
connected.
That's the key distinction.
Within that specific framework,
Trump isn't cast as one of the
insiders, one of the predators
in this Dark World.
Yeah, he's consistently seen as
the outsider, the one who wasn't
invited to the real party, the
one who wasn't initiated.
So while they might see him as
crude, maybe greedy, even pervy
in their eyes, he's definitely
not the kind of person involved
in those really dark, almost
fantastical rituals some
theories talk about.
Like sipping adrenochrome with
Klaus Schwab as the source puts.
Exactly that kind of thing.
He's painted more like the guy
who is rich enough to get close
to the temple, but dumb enough
to speak about it too loudly,
too publicly, and with too much
Queen's bravado to ever be
trusted by the real devils in
the room.
So his perceived flaws actually
reinforce his outsider status in
this context.
Precisely, that's why even
groups like you and I never
really placed him inside the
supposed pedo cult.
He was always positioned as its
would be exposer, the one
fighting against it, not part of
it.
That's a completely different
way of processing those kinds of
allegations.
It really is.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, it's also
important to remember Trump's
fundamental nature.
According to this analysis, he's
not really an ideologue in the
traditional sense, OK?
He is first and foremost an
operator.
He's transactional.
You know he wrote Art of the
Deal, not Mein Kampf.
Right at the dealmaker.
Yeah, he's described almost like
bubble with a red tie, that kind
of direct, maybe even
contradictory style.
A negotiator who uses momentum
and contradiction, not fixed
doctrine.
OK.
So he's pragmatic, maybe
transactional.
Very much so, and understanding
that leads to maybe the most
surprising conclusion in the
analysis.
Which is that?
The real danger to Trump has
never come from the left.
It comes from his own right
flank.
From his own side.
Yes, specifically from quote the
ones who have radicalized
themselves into purity spiral
suicide vests.
Wow.
OK, what does that mean?
It means those who are so rigid
in their ideology, so focused on
purity, that they'll attack
anyone, even potential allies
like Trump, if they perceive any
deviation or compromise.
The source specifically points
to groups like the Bannonists
and the Flintists.
And this connects to that term.
The source uses woke MAGA, which
sounds counterintuitive.
It does, but the source
clarifies it's not saying they
share ideology with the
progressive left.
Not at all.
It's saying they've adopted the
same absolutist logic, the same
refusal to horse trade, the same
posture of moral purity wrapped
in revolutionary urgency.
It's a similarity in tactics and
mindset, not beliefs.
So it's that uncompromising all
or nothing approach.
Exactly.
And according to this view,
these are the people calling
Trump a coward now, not the
liberals.
They're the ones attacking him
from the right for not being
extreme enough or pure enough.
It's like they're eating their
own in a way.
That's a good way to put it.
And This is why the ultimate
conclusion from our source
material is that Trump isn't
losing his base.
Not the core base, anyway.
He's shedding the performative
fringes, kind of burning off the
radicalized fat.
OK.
The analysis argues his enduring
core base remains solid.
Who are they?
The ones who voted for
deportation jobs, National
pride?
A nation that isn't ashamed to
still have borders or a flag?
The fundamentals.
And the others, the loud ones
online maybe?
The influencers, the content
spinners, the Never Trump folks
who flipped the Epstein watching
purity types.
The source basically dismisses
them as just white noise.
Wow.
Or worse, useful idiots chasing
shadows.
That's harsh, but it paints a
clear picture of their argument.
So bringing it back, when we see
a poll like the Pac-Man one or
any headline claiming a big
shift, what does this analysis
tell us about how we should
interpret that as people just
trying to follow the news?
Well, what that Pac-Man tweet
really represents, according to
this analysis, is something much
bigger and older.
It's called the perennial
liberal fantasy.
OK, the fantasy is that the
system will self correct once
the facts are clear enough.
It's this deep seated belief
that you know, a majority poll
means a majority shift in power.
Right, that numbers
automatically translate.
And that underlying assumption
that everyone still lives in a
shared moral reality where shame
is effective, where scandal
breaks loyalty, and where the
right truth at the right every
time makes the Empire blink.
But the argument is that's not
the world we live in.
The analysis puts it bluntly.
That world no longer exists.
Maybe it never did, but it
certainly doesn't now.
So what are we actually seeing
when these poles or scandals
hit?
We're seeing quote, not the Red
Hat unraveling.
We're watching people chase a
red herring again.
Chasing a red herring meaning.
Meaning they've mistaken
performative disapproval, like
someone answering a poll
question unfavorably, for actual
erosion of support.
They've confused a flash of
discontent in a poll with a sea
change in allegiance.
It's seeing what they hope to
see, essentially.
And the source predicts this
cycle will just keep going.
Yeah, and they'll do it again
next week when some new
headlines, some new gaffe, some
new out of context quote
confirms their hope that this
time it's different.
It becomes this almost
predictable pattern.
So the crucial take away, then,
from this whole deep dive seems
pretty clear.
Unless you really understand
what the Red Hat meant and still
means for those core supporters,
these political ups and downs,
these moments that feel like
breakthroughs, they're just
going to keep surprising you,
maybe frustrating you.
Because the simple, maybe
uncomfortable truth, as this
analysis argues it is that it
isn't different this time.
And until that basic dynamic is
grasped, until the reasons for
that loyalty, that withdrawal of
trust, are understood, then all
these attempts to force a
change, to land a killer blow,
they'll just keep missing the
mark.
How does the source put it?
It said they'll keep pulling the
trigger on kill shots that land
like Nerf darts in a storm.
Wow, Nerf darts in a storm.
That's quite the image it is.
And the final image the source
leaves us with is just.
And Trump, grotesque and golden,
will keep walking.
It really makes you think,
doesn't it?
Maybe consider how this analysis
changes how you look at the next
pool, the next headline.